[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und ich zeig euch jetzt wie man die
limonade herstellt ihr braucht es zuerst
einmal nur zwei grundzutaten und zwar
hier zitronen und zucker bis 4 15 kilo
bio zitrone der jetzt bereits gewaschen
und ich habe hier zucker da brauche ich
15 gläser genau die tröpfchen sieht man
auch und die werde ich jetzt erstmal in
feine scheiben schneiden und das macht
jetzt entweder mit messern oder einfach
mit der küchenmaschine und das mache ich
jetzt weil es schneller geht
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich das in eine große
schüssel rhein kann ich mir auch mit
reinschmeißen dann noch etwas zucker
erstmals klar
[Musik]
und noch mal ein halbes glas hatte
und diese brauchen wir den zucker und
das ganze wird es kurz verknetet ich
mach das mal kurz
damit sich einfach der zucker schön mit
dem zitronen verbindet
[Musik]
das darf man nicht trinken denn diese
zitronen zucker mischung muss jetzt erst
mal durchziehen damit sich auch der
zucker auflösen kann
und dann gibt die zitrone eben auch das
aroma an den zucker ab deswegen kommt es
jetzt im kühlschrank für etwa zwei bis
drei tage ich finde drei tage perfekt
und dann haben wir bald unser richtiges
schönes zitronen kunst im rat
[Musik]
jetzt drei tage später sieht das ganze
so aus also man sieht dass die zitronen
die den saft raus gelassen haben
er hat sich schon mit zucker verbunden
und dazu gehört sich aufgelegt jetzt
nehme ich zuerst mal so einen stampfer
und stampft die zitronen einfach damit
meinst du das machen
[Musik]
sieht man auch hier dass hier die der
saft der zitrone schön raus kommt der
zucker hat sich wunderbar aufgelöst
hoppala gleich keine regung mehr und es
riecht einfach richtig lecker erfrischen
jetzt drückt man hier die zitronen
einfach schön durch dass der saft
durchgeht
alternativ könnte das auch einfach mit
den händen machen wobei wir nicht dass
dadurch sieht hab da auch keine kerne
mit drin also ich finde zuschauer mit
klaus praktisch und du bist vielleicht
die verkäuferinnen
[Musik]
destinys bei mir 700 milliliter
konzentrat und es gebe ich jetzt hier in
ein glasgefäß ich habe extra jetzt und
limonaden gefäß oder hatten getränke
gibt es da kann eigentlich alles
mögliche drin machen und das würde ich
jetzt hier erst mal rein
[Musik]
gebe ich zu diesem konzentrat noch 15
liter wasser mit dazu das können wir je
nach geschmack machen aber ich finde das
so eigentlich ziemlich perfekt das ist
jetzt die fertige limonade und ich habe
es jetzt hier in so einem limonaden
behälter aber ihr könnt natürlich auch
ganz viele andere getränke einfüllen man
könnte limonade jetzt auch eine normale
karaffe einfühlen ohne deckel aber ich
finde ja ganz praktisch weil die haben
ihr sohn ausgießer und ich hab halt da
auch noch die passenden gläser mit dazu
vor allem wir mal draußen sitzt und im
freien kann es passieren dass man
insekten mit dem glas bekommt und da hat
man halt diese deckel mit dabei und
alles so schön verschlossen und vor
allem wenn es nach umfeld läuft halt
nicht raus und diese behälter und theke
getränke gläser die gibt's jetzt auch
bei uns im shop und ich hab das sogar
verschiedene varianten also da können
wir gerne mal reinschauen
da kommen jetzt eiswürfel rein lässt
sich auch ganz wichtig denn die limonade
schmeckt am besten so ein halbes glas
folgt und dann die limonade
[Musik]
und damit es noch richtig schön aussieht
kommen da ein paar zitronenscheiben mit
rein und ich geh jetzt noch kurz auf den
balkon und wollen wir etwas zwischen
[Musik]
und jetzt müssen die menschen auch
hinten kurz waschen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier noch einen grünen
apfel der kommt nämlich auch richtig gut
in der limonade und ich drücke das jetzt
gut es geht ganz sperren den schneide
ich jetzt nämlich ihren spalten und
durch die zitronensäure werden die jetzt
auch nicht braun wenn ihr das jetzt
einfach mit rein legt schmeckt auch
richtig lecker wenn man ihm später ist
und jetzt noch ein bisschen münze
[Musik]
die minzblätter frau aber kurz an
klatsche bekommen die ätherischen öle
gut raus rein und fertig ist unfrei
limonade schnaps probieren
wow
thomas wirtschaft mit dir machen
verkaufen erträglich
[Musik]